Part C find the value of the sixth
derivative of F evaluated at zero so you
can manage if you just want if you just
try to find the sixth derivative of F
that would take you forever and then to
evaluate it at zero because this is x
squared here and you'd have to keep
doing the product rule over and over
again the chain rule and all the rest
would become very very very messy but we
have a big clue here the fact that they
made us find the first four terms of the
Taylor series of F about x equals zero
tells us that there might be a simpler
way to do this as opposed to just taking
the sixth derivative of this and
evaluating at zero and the simplest way
to do this is to just go back in the
last problem we were able to come up
with the first four nonzero terms of the
Taylor series of F and if you look at
your definition of the Taylor series you
look at your definition of the Taylor
series right here and we're going to
depth this in another Khan Academy video
where we talk about why this makes sense
you see that each degree term of the
Taylor series its coefficient its
coefficient is that derivative and this
Taylor series is centered around zero
and that's what we care about in in
terms of this problem we see the
coefficient is that derivative divided
by divided by that degrees that
derivative evaluated at zero divided by
that degrees factorial so the second
degree term it's the second derivative
of F evaluated zero divided by 2
factorial the fourth degree term is the
fourth derivative is the fourth
derivative of F evaluated at 0 divided
by 4 factorial so the the sixth degree
term the sixth degree term let me let's
remind ourselves what we're even trying
to figure out so they they want us to
figure out the sixth derivative of F
evaluated at zero that's what they want
us to figure out well if you if you
think about the Taylor series centered
at zero or at zero or approximated
around zero the sixth degree term and
the Taylor series approximation of F is
going to be F prime of it's going to be
the sixth derivative of F evaluated at
zero times X to the sixth over
over six factorial this is going to be
the this is going to be the the sixth
degree term sixth degree term in Taylor
approximation in Taylor series Taylor
series and we have that term sitting
right over here this is the six degree
term we figured it out in the last
problem this right here is the sixth
degree term so you have X to the sixth
over here X to the six over here you
have six factorial over a year six
factorial over here so this negative 121
this negative 121 must be the sixth
derivative of F evaluated at zero so
that's our answer this is equal to
negative 121 and we're done